hey nice to meet you
um first Bravo con yes
I am so honored to be here it is so much
fun I love the excitement of everyone
and it really is like so exciting it's
so fun so pre-pandemic your mom came to
Toronto and we interviewed her there
um and she said she's just so proud of
watching you on this show when you look
back at your mom on the show what makes
you the most proud
honestly just the way that she's evolved
throughout all of the seasons because
like going back all the way to season
one like that was just like my hot head
Italian mom that I still love but like
that was the woman that raised me and
like made me the person I am today and
like with respect and everything but now
it's like she's my best friend like we
talk to each other on an everyday basis
like we're best friends I could talk to
her about everything and that's where
it's like she realized that realizes
that like I'm okay and now we could like
just talk like best friends so it's
awesome yeah she's like literally
amazing I love her so much
um obviously there's a lot of drama
right now in the family that I'm sure
we're gonna see play out on the season
being here at bravocon obviously you
know your uncle's like 10 feet away from
us is it awkward how does it feel
um yeah I'm just kind of walking my own
path
and what can you tease as far as the
season goes
I think you're just gonna see a lot of
Truth and I think you're really just
gonna see how it unfolds
um and last question you also became a
real Tick Tock sensation we've been
hearing the audio playing everywhere I
mean it's literally playing like
throughout the convention center yeah I
haven't even heard it no because I've
been like walking back behind stage and
like coming in that's crazy it surprise
you that blew up so many years later
well yeah because it happened like
literally 10 years ago so I was like
what the hell but honestly it has been
an amazing experience it brought me into
an amazing business opportunity with
hazel Boutique I have my own clothing
line and I am so happy and I love all my
fans for supporting me for it
yes thanks so much thank you so much